what did you think of it i really
enjoyed it and you know it covered lots
of the areas that i wanted to to cover
and they were great questions yeah any
questions surprise you
um no i don't think so i mean i think we
had a pretty good broad range and that's
great yeah do you feel this is a good
format to get your policies across i
think it definitely is i mean the
standing up is really interesting
because it creates a more dynamic
environment and it's and it's great to
get your young people involved in
politics people who who are all a lot of
them bloggers vloggers all the rest of
it yeah it's a chance to give them more
of a stage and for other people to think
maybe i could do that too
how prepared are you for the leaders to
be
um oh i'm very much looking forward to
them you know for the green party it's
really going to be transformational that
people have the chance to hear about our
policies like making the minimum wage a
living wage renationalizing the railways
keeping our nhs publicly owned and
publicly run and i think once more
people hear about that they'll very much
like what they hear okay finally when
did you get your bike in the end um i
started i started to learn as a teenager
and so because you're a bit more scared
of falling over when you're a teenager i
sort of hopped up and down with one leg
on the ground for quite a while okay
thank you very much cheers thank you